[موسيقى]
مع تصاعد المعارك في السودان ايجاد تعقد
قمه في جيبوتي لدعوه للحوار ووقف النار
بعد تحقيق اول مكاسبه في الجيش الاوكراني
يوسع هجومه المضاد ويساعد في ضخمه
في رساله موجهه لروسيا النيتو يبدا اكبر
مناوره جويه في تاريخه بتنسيق من المانيا
تجدد التوتر على الحدود الافغانيه
الايرانيه وسط خلافات بين البلدين على حصه
مياه نهرها البنت
نبدا ساعتنا الاخباريه من التصعيد العسكري
في السودان حيث تستمر للشبكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في اكثر من جبهه في الخرطوم
تركزت المعارك التي استخدمت فيها الاسلحه
الثقيله في وسط وغرب العاصمه وفي ام درمان
فيما وردت انباعا سيطره الجيش على محيط
جسر الحلفايه في مدينه بحر الشمالي
الخرطوم وتجدد القصف المدفعي تجاه تمركزات
الدعم السريع في ام درمان
[موسيقى]
وقد اعلن الجيش السوداني ان قواته كبدت
عناصر الدعم السريع خسائر فادحه منذ بدء
المعارك بين الطرفين في منتصف شهر ابريل
الماضي وذكر الجيش ان خسائر قوات الدعم
شملت مقتل مئات العناصر بالاضافه الى
تدمير عشرات الاليات العسكريه وفق الجيش
وذكر الجيش السوداني ان قواته قامت
بعمليات تمشيط في منطقه الشجره الجنوبيه
الخرطوم والجسر الحلفايه وشرق النيل لافتا
الى ان قوات الدعم السريع تتخفى بالملابس
المدنيه وتستخدم سيارات مدنيه منهوبه في
تحركاتها كما تحتمي بمنازل المواطنين كما
يقول الجيش السوداني
ولمعاينه الوضع في الخرطوم ما نذهب الى
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه ليطلعنا اكثر على
مزيد من التفاصيل عمار اهلا بك معنا في
هذه الساعه الاخباريه على العربيه اين
تتركز الاشتباكات في الخرطوم بتحديد اليوم
يبدو مختلفا عن الامس حيث امس كانت هنالك
عده اشتباكات عنيفه في عدد كبير من الرجال
العاصمه الخرطوم بيان الجيش الذي صبر قبل
اللحظات اشار الى عده نقاط مهمه من ابرزها
العمليات العسكريه التي ظهرت بالامس
والجيش اشار الى انه قام بعدد من التمشيط
عمليات التمشيط في عدد من المناطق خاصه
المناطق الشجره التي يتواجد فيها اكبر
معسكر للجيش واهم الوحدات العسكريه معسكر
المدرعات وايضا في هذه المنطقه بالقرب
منها كنا نشاهد وحتى اللحظه ارتفاع الدخان
من مستودعات الغاز التي تحترق لاكثر من
خمسه ايام اليوم يبدو الوضع مختلفا حيث
عدد من الاشتباكات المتفرقه والخفيفه في
عدد من انحاء العاصمه الخرطوم خاصه
الشمالي مدينه بحري وايضا مدينه ام در في
غرب المدينه حيث استمع شهود عيال لعدد من
اصوات الانفجارات في هذه المنطقه ولكنها
لم
كثيرا هنا في شرق العاصمه بشكل اكبر اذا
ما تحدثنا عن ولايه الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث
الخرطوم وانظر الخرطوم بحري هل الحسم
العسكري وفق المعطيات على الارض لصالح
الجيش
نعمل الجنس دائما يؤكد ذلك من خلال
عده جير الى ان الوضع العمليات المستقر في
عدد من الولايات السودانيه بينما هنالك
عدد من المناطق تشهد توترات امنيه وعمليات
قتال عنيفه ما بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
العاصمه الخرطوم الدعم السريع من جانب اخر
ايضا يبث عدد من البيانات ويؤكد انه يسيطر
على العاصمه الخرطوم بنسبه كبيره وبالامس
دارت معارك طاحنه ما بين الجيش والدعم
السريع في منطقه شرق النيل وبس الدعم
السريع عدد من الفيديوهات لهذه
المعارك بيان الجيش الاخير الذي قضى لحظات
تحدث فيه الى عده نقاط عسكريه مهمه يشير
الى انه كبد الدعم السريع عدد من الخسائر
الكبيره في الاليات والجنود الان يبدو
الوضع هادئا نادين ولكن بحسب البيانات
الرسميه ما بين الجانبين استمرار المعارك
يعني ان عمليات الحزب العسكري مستمره
الطرفين حتى ان عدد من الجهات الخارجيه
ايضا اشير الى ان عمليات عسكريه تبدو صعبه
في العاصمه الخرطوم عدد من الميسرين وعدد
من الفاعلين في المنطقه يرون ان الحل هو
في الجلوس للتفاوض بدلا من عمليات الحكومه
ضيفنا بعد قليل في الشق السياسي حتى هذه
الساعه عمار نريد ان نعرف مزيد من
التفاصيل فيما يتعلق بجسر حلفايه ما مصيره
حتى هذه الساعه
نعم يعني بالامس
شهود عنود تحدثوا استطاع العبور من هذه
المنطقه وتقدم فيها كثيرا الدعم السريع ده
مساء بانه مازال متواجد في محيط المنطقه
وانه يسيطر على المنطقه اذا الضبابيه في
المشهد الذي تبدو واضحه بشكل كبير باعتبار
ان عمليات الحزب العسكري والعمليات
العسكريه تدور بالقرب من هذا المكان ما
بين
ذلك طوال طوال فتره هذه الحرب منذ عده
ايام دائما ما يتقدم طرف في منطقه ومن ثم
يتقدم الاخر بعض لحظات والعكس صحيح في هذه
النقاط يبدو عمليات الجزمه بالتاكيد
المباشر لمن السيطره ولمن تسير الامور
يبدو صعبا جدا خاصه وان نمضي نحو الشهر
الثالث من القتال ومن الحرب المستعره منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل ولكن دعيني اذهب معك
نادين الى ولايه دارفور حيث اليوم كان
هنالك تصريحا مهما جدا من مكتب التحالف
النسوي في دارفور الذي اشار الى هدوء في
فزع وانهيار في الجنينه واشارت هذه
المجموعه النسويه في بيان الى ان جهات
طبيه بالمنطقه ذكرت وفاه بان اكثر من خمسه
وثمانين اوم في حاله ولاده تعرضت للوفاه
وهذا رقم كبير جدا في المنطقه ما يشير الى
سوء الاحوال سواء كانت في العاصمه الخرطوم
او في ولايات دارفور يبدو الوضع الانساني
كارثيا بشكل كبير وايضا عدد من المعلومات
التي ترد رغم انها شحيحه من ولايه دارفر
حتى من العاصمه الخرطوم كعدد من المناطق
التي تدور فيها اشتباكات يبدو الوضع
كارثيا في عدد كبير من الانحاول انا اشكرك
على كل هذه الاحاطه شكرا لك من الخرطومه
الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه
على وقع التصعيد في السودان تعقد الهيئه
الحكوميه للتنميه ايجاد قمه في جيبوتي
لاقناع طرفي الازمه باجراء حوار ينهي
القتال بينهما ويضع حدا للحرب دائره وجاء
هذا عقب قمه افريقيه مصغره استضافتها
جيبوتي اول امس والتي شارك فيها رؤساء
الجنوب السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي الجانبيه
قال رئيس جيبوتي دول اجاكسا تدرس سبل
اقناع الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع باجراء
حوار كفيلا بوقف اطلاق النار بشكل فعلي في
المرحله المقبله
قبل ذلك قالت السعوديه وامريكا في بيان
مشترك ان الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع اظهرها سيطره فعاله على قوتهما
خلال هدنه ال 24 ساعه الاخيره وادنت
السعوديه وامريكا بشده تجدد العنف في
السودان فور انتهاء الهدنه اكد طرفان
استعدادهما الاستئناف المباحثات اذا تقيد
طرف صراع باعلان جده كما اكد ان الحل
العسكري للصراع في السودان غير مقبول
نذهب الان الى القاهره معنا من هناك الصحه
في السوداني عبد الله الشيخ عبد الله اهلا
بك معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه على
العربيه طالما اظهر طرفات صراع السيطره
فعاله على قواتهما خلال هدنه ال 24 ساعه
لماذا لا يمكن تطويرها لتضم اكثر وتطول
طيب شكرا
طبعا الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه
حين اصدرت هذا هذا التصريح
هنالك كلمه مهمه جدا وهي مفتاحيه في
وصف ما يدور في جده الان بان الحسم
العسكري لهذه الازمه او لهذا الصراع غير
مقبول وهذه كلمه مهمه جدا من الناحيه
الاخرى نلاحظ انه المفاوضات التي تدور في
جده هي مفاوضات غير مباشره بين الطرفين
وبالتالي هذه تفارق العاده السودانيه
في انه دائما كانت المفاوضات تدور بين
طرفين وكانوا هذين الطرفين السودانيين
يكون يكونان في
طاوله المفاوضات اما الان في جده فيلاحظ
انه الوسطاء او الوساطه الامريكيه
السعوديه تحاول ان تخاطب الطرفين كلا على
حده ما يعني ان الحل الذي سياتيه
يكون بالتاكيد
مبنيا على تجربه الطرفين على تجربه
الوسيطين السعودي والامريكي
عسكري غير مقبول من قبل الاطراف السياسيه
لكن اذا ما تحدثنا عن طرفي الصراع هل يمكن
حسم المعركه بحل بحل سياسي دبلوماسي ام ان
كل من الطرفين يريد مزيدا من الدماء ويريد
حسم عسكريا ولا يمكن ان يقبل بذلك بعد
ثلاثه اشهر من بدء المعركه
التجربه تشير الى ان الحسم العسكري غير
مقبول اولا وغير ممكن كذلك وان كان هدف
الجيش السوداني في المرحله الاخيره او كما
يبدو من تجربه الامس وتجربه اليوم انه
يسعى نحو تحقيق نصر محدد
لكي يواجه الدعم السريع
بنتائج اخرى في داخل المحادثات في جده
ولكن هذا الحسم غير ممكن وان كان يعني من
الممكن تحقيق على مدى طويل ولكن الراي
العام المحلي والدولي والوسطاء لا يقبلون
بمثل هذا بمثل هذه المجازفه وبالتالي ليس
هنالك حل عسكري باي حال من الاحوال لهذا
الصراع وبالتالي لابد من الرجوع الى
الوساطه في جده وانا اعتقد انه ما يدور
الان في جيبوتي من دول الايجاد كانها
الحاله بتاعه الحاق لهذه
الكيان لهذه الدول دول الايجاد بانها يعني
تحاول في مبادره اخرى لحل الازمه
السودانيه اعتقد ان هذا طيب ولكن يفترض ان
لا تتعدد المبادرات في الازمه السودانيه
بالنظر الى التجربه التاريخيه
للسودانيين مثل هذه المحادثات ان تعدد
المبادرات وتعدد المنابر هذا يؤذي كثيرا
امكانيه الوصول الى حل للازمه
كج
زيره نحو عشره الاف شخص من الفارينه من
الاشتباكات في السودان اوضاعا معيشيه
بالغه التعقيد في مخيم الجامعه المؤقت
بمقاطعه الرنك بولايه اعالي النيل في جنوب
السودان ويتخوف الكثيرون من تفشي الامراض
نتيجه انتشار ذباب بشكل مخيف وزير الشؤون
الانسانيه الذي زار المخيم قال ان
المساعدات التي تقدمها الحكومه والمنظمات
الانسانيه شحيحه جدا مقارنه بحجم العالقين
في المخيم
اكثر من عشره الاف شخص من الفرينه من
الاشتباكات في السودان يحتضنهم هذا المخيم
بمدينه الرنك في ولايه اعالي النيل
المتاخمه لولايه النيل الابيض السودانيه
حيث يعيشون ظروفا انسانيه بالغه التعقيد
وهم ينتظرون ترحيلهم الى مناطقهم الاصليه
جنوبيه السودان
اكثر من اللازم وقاعدين وما في اي فائده
من غياب الخدمات الغذائيه والصحيه اضافه
الى اكتظار المخيم بالعالقين عدى الى تفشي
الكثير من الامراض خاصه الاسهالات المائيه
بين الاطفال وكبار السن
ويتخوف الكثيرون من تفشي الامراض بعد
انتشار الذباب بشكل مخيف
لمن الراجل كبير
ده كله من الاسهالات
وزير الشؤون الانسانيه الذي زار المخيم
قاله ان جهود وزارته بالاضافه الى جهود
المنظمات الانسانيه ضايله جدا
وبالكادله تسد احتياجات الناس
مقارنه بالتزايد المستمر لعدد الفرنه
يوميا ما قد يفاقم من ازمه ايواءهم هنا
بعد اشهر من التعثر البرلمان العراقي يقر
الميزانيه الجديده
اهلا بكم ونتابع معكم الاجتماع الوزاري
الثاني بين دول العربيه ومجموعه جزر
باسيفيك فهذه كلمه للامين العام لجامعه
الدول العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
السياسيه والاقتصاديه والثقافات وغيرها من
المجالات الهامه للجانبين
وتدرك جامعه الدول العربيه باهتمام تطلعات
ومخاوف دونكم الموقره ولقد قطعتم الاف
الاميال من منتقم صوب ومنطقتنا وهذا انما
يعكس حرصكم على تقريب وجهات النظر ازاء
القضايا المختلفه وتشارك وتشارك الطموحات
نحو مستقبل افضل لدوالنا وشعوبنا ونود ان
نؤكد ان الجانب العربي مستعد للتعاون معكم
في مختلف المجالات ذات الاهتمام المشترك
والتي من بينها قضايا تغير المناخ مثلما
تحدثتم والاستجابه للاوبئه والامن البحري
وحمايه البيئه والامن الصحي وكلها نقاط
تحدثتم فيها ان كلا كلا من المنطقتين
العربيه
والباسفيكيه تحتل مكانه جو استراتيجيه
هامه في ظل نظام الدوليه الحالي الامر
الذي يدعون الى ودعم التعاون جنوب جنوب من
اجل التعبير عن الاراده الحره والمستقله
لدولنا وشعوبنا وهنا اود ان اؤكد على
اهميه الدعم المتبادل بين الدول العربيه
ودول جزر الفسيفك في الموضوعات المطروحه
في الامم المتحده والمنظمات الدوليه فيما
يتعلق بالقضايا العادله للطرفين وكذلك
الدعم المتبادل للترشيحات للمناصب في
المناظر في المنظمات الدوليه ونحن مستعدون
لان نسمع من جانبكم المزيد حول قضاياكم
اسمحوا لي في هذا الاطار ان اطلعكم على
اخر التطورات والمستجدات على الساعه
العربيه
فان القضيه الفلسطينيه تقع على راس اجنده
الدبلوماسيه العربيه وستواصل الدول
العربيه حمل لواء الدفاع عن هذه القضيه في
مختلف المحافل الدوليه وفي مقدمتها الامم
المتحده ونتطلع في هذا الاطار الى تفهم
دوركم الموقره لهذا المسح العربي ودعمنا
فيه ودعمنا فيه في الامم المتحده وهنا
ادعوكم للاستماع الى ابعاد المشهد الراهب
في فلسطين
والاعتداءات الاسرائيليه المتكرره من
معالي الوزير رياض المالكي وزير الخارجيه
وشؤون المغتربين بدوله فلسطين
ولذلك ولا زالت جامعه الدول العربيه تعمل
جاهده من اجل التوصل الى حلول سياسيه
للازمات العربيه الراهنه بما يحفظ
مقدراتها ووحداتها ووحداتها الترابيه
وسلامه مؤسساتها الوطنيه كما سنواصل العمل
من اجل اخلاء منطقه الشرق من اسلحه الضمار
الشامل على غرار المنطقه الخاليه في منطقه
جنوب الباسيفيك وعلى الصعيد التنمويه فان
الدول العربيه تضع مساله التنميه
المستدامه على راس اولوياتها في الوقت
الراهن وسنعمل على التنسيق مع دول جزر
الباسيفيك خاصه في ظل في اطار الرؤى
والمبادرات التنمويه العربيه والتي من
بينها رؤيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه 2030
اخيرا الحضور الكريم نتطلع الى ان يفهم
اجتماعنا اليوم في وضع حجر اساس للتعاون
العربي الفلسفيكي في اطار مؤسسي يضمن
الاستدامه والتطور لهذا التعاون من خلال
العمل على ابرام وثقه تاسس لمنتدى تعاون
عربي
في مختلف المجالات المجالات يتضمن اليات
واضحه ذات دوريه عقاضا تضمن عقد لقاءات
منتظمه للمسؤولين من الجانبين
اجدد شكري وتقديري لحكومه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وزاره الخارجيه تحت قياده سمو
الامير فيصل بن فرحان على استضافه هذا
الاجتماع متمنيا لاعماله النجاح والتوفيق
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
شكرا معالي الامين العام على كلمتكم
الضافيه واعلن بذلك انتهاء مراسم افتتاح
الاجتماع الوزاري المشترك الثاني بين
الدول العربيه والمجموعه الدول جزر وادعو
وسائل الاعلام للتفضل لمغادره القاعه
لنستانف اعمالنا في جلسه العمل المغلقه
شكرا
اذا نقلنا لكم هذه المتابعه لاجتماع
الوزاري المشترك بين دول العروبيه ودول
باسيفك في الرياض طبعا هذا الاجتماع هو
ثاني المشترك بين الدول امين عام جامعه
الدول العربيه احمد ابو الغيط كان اكد
اكثر من مره في كلمته التي تابعناها قبل
قليل على ان هناك تعاونا اكبر بين الدول
العربيه ودول الباسيفيك ويجب وضع حجر اساس
بين دول العربيه ودول الباسيفيك وايضا
المزيد من التعاون بين الجانبين وطبعا
نشير الى ان وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل
بن فرحان كان اكد على دعم سياده الدول
باستقلالها وحل النزاعات اذا في المنطقه
كان هذا ابرز ما جاء في الشمال الوزاره
المشتركه بين الدول العربيه ودول باسيفيك
في الرياض نستكمل في اخبار هذه النشره بعد
تحقيقها اولى مكاسبها في دنياتسك وسعت
القوات الاوكرانيه هجومها المضاد واعلنت
انها تخوض معارك عنيفه مع الروسيه في
باخمت واكدت قياده الاركان في الجيش
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه تتكبدت خسائر
كبيره في اتجاه بخموت وان المحاولات
الروسيه لشن هجمات مضاده قربى بلدتي
بيلاجورا وايفونسكي فشلت
نذهب الى كييف وضعنا من هناك الصحفي محمد
البابا اهلا بك محمد معنا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه على العربيه اين وصلت القوات
الاوكرانيه في هجومها المضاد
نعم يعني بعد يعني التقدم الكبير الذي
حصل القوات
الروسيه في مقاطعه في جنوب غرب مقابل
مقاطعه القوات الاوكرانيه
واستطعت السيطره على خمس بلدات وهي الان
تقوم قتال عنيف وشرس جدا في قريه نوفي
ماريسكا التي تقع جنوب قريه مكاريوسكا
التي سيطرت عليها القوات الاوكرانيه وايضا
في مقاطعه الاوكرانيه استطاعت السيطره على
على قريه نوفي دارسكا التي تقع في مقاطعه
الاوكرانيه تشل ضربات وهجمات عنيفه
بهدف الوصول الى مدينه
ميليتوفيل التي قصفتها القوات الاوكرانيه
بالامس استهدفت مخازن الاسلحه للقوات
الروسيه ايضا معارك شرسه داخل يعني في
المنطقه الشماليه لمدينه القوات
الاوكرانيه دخلت واستطاعت السيطره على
اطراف مدينه الاطراف الشماليه لمدينه
وتتقدم وتحقق يعني بحسب ضباط في الجيش
الاوكراني تحقيق تقدم بشكل بطيء ولكن مهم
مع تراجع القوات الروسيه التي حاولت من
الجهه الجنوبيه مباغته القوات الاوكرانيه
بهجوم على
ان القوات الاوكرانيه استطاعت سد هذا
الاوزون ايضا في محور الايمان اكريميني
القوات الاوكرانيه كسرت
الدفعه يعني نها
ر امس صباح الاولى
استطعتم حوالي بين 300 الى كيلو متر في
تلك المنطقه يعني الجيش الاوكراني بدا
يوسع جبهات القتال بشكل كبير في يعني في
كثافه نيران كبيره القوات الروسيه تعاني
من نقص في العتاد والذخيره بعدما قام
الجيش الاوكراني على مدى فلا اسابيع بقصف
جميع وتدمير جميع المخازن المخازن الكبرى
للاسلحه والعتاب التي تقع في داخل مدينه
وحتى في الكره الحدوديه او المناطق
الحدوديه مع روسيا من الجهه الشماليه شكرا
جزيلا شكرا محمد البابا من كيف
في رساله موجهه لروسيا انطلقت تدريبات
لحلف شمال الاطلسي بتنسيق من المانيا
والتي تعد اكبر المناورات الجويه في تاريخ
النيتو وتستمر حتى الثالث والعشرين من
يونيو تهدف المناورات الى اظهار وحده
الاعضاء في مواجهه اي تهديدات محتمله حيث
ستشارك قرابه 250 طائره عسكريه من 25 دوله
عضو في الاطلس وشركه له بما في ذلك
اليابان سويد الدوله المرشحه العضويه
الحلف اضافه الى مشاركه ما يصل الى عشره
الاف شخص في هذه التدريبات خصوصا في
المانيا وايضا في جمهوريه تشيك واستونيا
كما ستعزز هذه التدريبات توافقيه التشغيل
والحمايه من الطائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ
كروز في حال وقوع هجوم على مدن او مطارات
او موانئ او واقع على اراضي دول الحلف
نذهب الى موسكو ومعنا من هناك المحلل
السياسي فيتش سلاف ماتازوف سيد مرحبا بك
معنا في هذه السالخباريه اهلا بك كيف
تتابع موسكو اكبر المناورات الجويه في
تاريخ النيتو
اولا انا ليست هذا فقط المناورات الجويه
العسكريه
وحلفائهم اما هناك كذلك حسب المعلومات
العسكريه عندنا هناك مناورات القوات
الاستراتيجيه بحريه كذلك كل الغواصات
الامريكيه مثل اوهايو وغيرها قد خرجوا على
الاستنفار
لامكانيه بدا ضربه
استراتيجيه على روسيا لذلك هذا
المناورات الجويه في اوروبا
تترافقوا هذه المناورات
الهجوم المضاد كما يرسمون في اوكرانيا
ونحن نسميها كهجوم
على دعمها المستمر لمبادئ الشرعيه الدوليه
الراميه للحفاظ على الامن والسلم الدوليين
وتعزيز التعاون المشترك المبني على اسس
الاحترام المتبادله لسياده الدول
واستقلالها وحل النزاعات بالطرق السلميه
وعدم التصعيد واللجوء الى القوه او
التهديد بها
وبناء على هذا الاساس فاننا نستحضر دائما
واولا قضيه رئيسيه القضيه الفلسطينيه التي
نسعى منذ عقود لايجاد الحل العادل والشامل
لها وفق قرارات الشرعيه الدوليه ومبادره
السلام العربيه فعمليه بناء السلام وتغلب
على التحديات وتحقيق تنميه اقتصاديه شامله
تتطلب العمل الجماعي المشترك وتعزيز
الشراكات واثراء التبادل الثقافي
والحضاريه والاجتماعيه وتقديم الدعم
المتبادل بين الدول العربيه ودول الجزر
الفاسي في الموضوعات المطروحه في المنظمات
الدوليه الاخوه الكرام تولي المملكه حرصا
كبيرا لمواجهه التحديات العالميه المشتركه
والاكثر الحاحا كالامن الغذائي والعقباء
والعقبات التي تواجهها سلاسل الامداد
والتغير المناخي والتنميه المستدامه
وادراكا من المملكه باهميه التعامل مع
تحديات التغير المناخي وضروره معالجه
اثاره السلبيه
ان هاتولي بالغ الاهتمام في تحقيق اهداف
اتفاقيه باريس للتغيير المناخي ومن هذا
المنطق ومنطلق فقط اعطت من المملكه
الاولويه لاهميه توجيه الاقتصاد المحلي
والعالمي نحو انتعاش اكثر استدامه من خلال
تقديمها لمبادرات النوعيه تهم المنطقه
والعالم حيث اعلن صاحب السمنه الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ولي
العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء حفظ الله عن
مبادره هي المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الخضراء والشرق الاوسط الاخضر وذلك
استمرارا لجهودها للحفاظ على البيئه وبما
يتماشى مع رؤيتها عشرون ثلاثون
كما تتطلع المملكه الى دفع بالمصالح
المشتركه مع دول الجزر الفاسي وتعزيز
التعاون في مجالات الامن والطاقه والتجاره
والاستثمار والخدمات اللوجستيه
وتفعيل دور القطاع الخاص للبحث عن فرص
استثماريه تعود بالنفع المشترك على
بلداننا وشعوبنا
ومن اجل تعزيز التعاون في مختلف المجالات
فان المملكه العربيه السعوديه تسعى
للانضمام لمنظمه المنتدى جزر
كشريك حوار
وفي الختام تجدد المملكه تطلع اهل العمل
معكم جميعا لتعزيز استقرار وامن دولنا
وحشت الجهود والامكانات للنموضيه قدما في
مسار التنميه والازدهار لبناء مستقبل تنعم
به اجيالنا القادم والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
يؤكد على حرص المملكه في دعم سياده الدول
واستقلالها وحل النزاعات في المنطقه وان
التحديات العالميه تتطلب تعزيز التعاون
المشترك وان المملكه العربيه السعوديه طول
اهتماما بقضايا الامن الغذائي والتغير
المناخي في الوقت الذي قدمت فيه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه مبادره نوعيه لمكافحه
التغير المناخي كان هذا ابرز ما جاء في
كلمه وزير الخارجيه السعودي نعود الى
ضيفنا من موسكو المحلل السياسي بيتشي سلاف
ماتازون للحديث اكثر حول المناورات الجويه
او اكبر مناورات جويه في تاريخ النيتو
اليوم وفي رساله موجهه الى موسكو السيد
اليوم كيف ستتلقف موسكو هذه الرسائل وكيف
سترد
الرسائل هذا كانت متوقعه ونحن كنا نتحدث
معكم منذ شهر تقريبا ان في فتره ما بين
ثلاث اثنا عشر او ثلاثه اشهر يونيو حتى 25
يونيو
حلف شمال الاطلسي يخطط
مناورات اكبر مناورات في تاريخ خلف الناتو
ولذلك اذا صار نحن نشاهد هذا المناورات
ولكن هذا تحذير للروسيا بلا اي شاب تاجير
الروشا الاستراتيجيه
وبرايه انا قرار القياده الروسيه سيكون
على نفس الحزم لا تتراجع روسيا من تطبيق
خطتها في اوكرانيا اولا لانه هذا كله
مناورات الجويه بحريه استراتيجيه مرتبطه
مع عمليه عسكريه في اوكرانيا
غرب وقف وقفا واضحا تماما
ولذلك روسيا عندما باتت عمليه عسكريه كانت
تنطلق من الفكره ان القوات العسكريه حلف
ودول غربيه هو من عوامل خطيره لامن القومي
الروسي والان خلال هذه السنه خلال هذا
العمليه عسكريه في اوكرانيا
روسيا يتخذت هذا قرار لبدء العمليه عسكريه
بريه انا وهي كانت لها العلم انه هي
تستخدم ليست مع اوكرانيا اما تصطدم مع
ولايات المتحده الامريكيه وحلف الشمال
طبعا هذا كل شيء متواضع بتقرير الرسميه
عندنا
يتحدثون ان الجيش الروسي مستعد
لمواجهه لمواجهه في اوكرانيا ولكن على نفس
الوقت جيش روسيا مساله كل شيء متوقع هل
يمكن ان يسمح وتسمح دول النيتو وحتى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لان يكون هناك
صراع عسكري مباشر بين الاطراف على ارض
اوكرانيا
هذا هو تهديد كل المناورات اللي ذكرته انا
هذا
تهزير خزر لروسيا ان الغرب مستعد ان
يرجعوا الى هذه
السلاح
الاستراتيجي وطبعا انا اعتبر انه
لا
يلجا لهذا الاساليب الدعم لجيش اوكراني
هذا من ممكن ان نقول انا من الناحيه الاف
سيكولوجيه النفسيه التي محاوله تؤثر على
على
وجهه النظر او على مزاج القوات الروسيه
والقياده الروسيه يطلبهم هند تراجع انا
اتشاور انا هذا حسابات الغربيه خاطئه
روسيا لم تتراجع امام هذه التهديدات على
الاستعداد
ليشاركوا باي
شروط بيئيه ظروف بيئيه
امكانيات المتواصل شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
المحلل
بعد اشهر من التعثر والخرافات اقر مجلس
نواب العقيقه قانون الموازنه العامه لثلاث
سنوات والتي بلغت 153 مليار دولار لكل عام
تشمل الميزانيه انفاقا قياسيا على فاتوره
اجور حكوميه ومشروعات تهدف لتحسين الخدمات
واعاده بناء البنيه التحتيه ياتي تصويت
بعد حاله من الجدل اثر اعتراضات كتل
سياسيه حول اليه دفع اقليم كردستان لحصه
النفط وتتخذ الميزانيه خطوات لمعالجه
الخلافات طويله الامد بين العراق وكردستان
اذ من المقرر ايداع عائدات النفط في حساب
يشرف عليه البنك المركزي العراقي
الاخباريه مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
اختراق جديد للمضيق ترصد عبور مقاتلات
صينيه خط المنتصف
مع تصاعد المعارك في السودان ايجاد تعقد
قمه في جيبوتي لدعوه للحوار ووقف النار
بعد تحقيق اول مكاسبه في دنيتك الجيش
الاوكراني يوسع هجومه المضاد ويساعد في
بخموت
في رساله مواجهه لروسيا نيتو يبدا اكبر
مناوره جويه في تاريخه بتنسيق من المانيا
تجدد التوتر على الحدود الافغانيه
الايرانيه وسط خلافات بين البلدين على حصه
مياه نهر المجد
اعلنت مصادر الفلسطينيه ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعتقل سته فلسطينيين من مناطق
متفرقه بضفه الغربيه وغزه اوضحت المصادر
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعتقل الفلسطينيين
خلال عمليات اقتحام في الخليل ونابلس
ومخيم الجلزون بالاضافه الى عمليه اقتحام
في بلده رمانه في محافظه جنين شهدت
اشتباكات بين الفلسطينيين والقوات
الاسرائيليه
اكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان اي اتفاق سيتم
التوصل اليه بشان الملف النووي سيحمي
مصالح ايران ويراعي الخطوط الحمراء قال
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر
كنعاني ان ايران لا تجري اي مباحثات
لابرام اتفاق نوويا وقت او جديد وان اي
تفاوض يجب ان يكون على اساس اتفاق 2015
واشار ايضا الى احتماليه حدوث تبادل
للسجناء مع واشنطن قريبا اذا اظهرت
الولايات المتحده حسن النيه
تجددت في اليومين الاخيرين الاشتباكات بين
القوات الايرانيه وحركه طالبا عند نقطه
حدوديه واقعه في محافظه زابل الايرانيه
وفق ما فادت به وكاله ارنا الرسميه عن حرس
الحدود الايراني ياتي الحادث في سياق
توترات المتواصله بين طهران وكابل حول
توزيع مياه نهرها المد حيث طالب رئيس
منظمه حمايه البيئه الايرانيه طالب الجانب
الافغاني بالامتثال للمطالب الايرانيه
بشان المعاهده المتفق عليها سابقا والتي
تحول لطهران الحصول على
820 مليون متر مكعب من المياه القادمه من
افغانستان
على كل حال نتابع المزيد من التفاصيل عن
الصراع المائي طويل الامد بين البلدين مع
الزميل فارس صلواته
ازمه الحدود بين البلدين التي تفجرت اخيرا
بين ايران وافغانستان اعادت خلافا قديما
يعود الى السبعينيات خلاف مائي يدور حول
تقسم البلدين نهر هيلماند نهر هيلماند يعد
اطول نهر في افغانستان واهم مورد للماء
لكل من كابول وطهران باعتباره شريانا
رئيسيا تعتمد عليه حياه السكان على الحدود
الافغانيه الايرانيه يبلغ طوله
2150 كيلومترا وهو ينبع من جبال هندوكوش
في الشمال الشرقي من افغانستان ثم يصب في
بحيره هامون في الاراضي الايرانيه من اهم
روافد من اهم روافده نهر الغنداب وايضا
نهر تارناك هنا يجب ان نعرف بان النهر
يدخل ايران مرورا بمنطقه سيستان وبلوشستان
قبل ان يصل الى مصبه في البحيره وهو واحد
من بين انهار تشترك فيها افغانستان مع
جيرانها مثل نهر امو المشترك مع تاجكستان
اوزباكستان وتركمانستان الحكومات
الافغانيه المتعاقبه حرصت على بناء عدد من
السدود على نهر هيلماند بهدف تخزين المياه
وزياده توليد الطاقه الكهرومائيه منها سد
كاجاكي وسد كمال خان الذي يقع في الجنوب
الغربي ولتنظيم التوزيع العادل لمياه
النهر وقع البلدان اتفاقيه قديمه قبل
خمسين عاما الاتفاقيه تكفل لطهران الحصول
على 26 مترا مكعبا من المياه في الثانيه
الواحده وعلى هذا الاساس يتدفق الى ايران
سنويا 820 مليون متر مكعب من المياه
القادمه من افغانستان غير ان الاتفاقيه لم
تحل الخلافه بين الجانبين طهران ترى بان
السدود الافغانيه تحول دون تدفق المياه
اراضيها بالشكل الكافي منذ ان اعلنت
الحكومه الافغانيه استكمال قرار بناء
السدود واداره المياه لمعالجه ازمه الجفاف
مشيره الى انها خاسره العامه الماضي نحو
اربعه ملايين متر مكعب من المياه القادمه
من افغانستان غير ان طالبان عزت سبب تراجع
تدفق المياه لايران الى قله هطول الامطار
افغانستان تحصل على 57 مليار متر مكعب من
متوسط مياه الانهار السنوي لكنها لا
تستهلك سوى 30% من هذه الكميه اذا قضيه
الانهار الحدوديه ورفع العوائق امام حلها
هما الرهان الرئيسي والذي تراه طهران
معيارا مهما بالنسبه لتطور العلاقات بين
البلدين
اذا نتابع معكم هذا العاجل وفاه رئيس
الوزراء الايطاليه سيلفيا وبيلسكوني اذا
وفقا لوكاله الانباء الفرنسيه تتحدث عن
وفاه رئيس الوزراء الايطالي سيلفيو وطبعا
نشير الى انه كان سياسيا رجل اعمال
لايطالي وكان رئيسا لوزراء ايطاليا لمده
ثلاث مرات في ايطاليا بالتحديد وكان يلقب
باسم الفارس نظرا للتكريم الذي كان حصل
عليه في عام
1977 وطبعا نشير بانه كان رئيس الوزراء
الايطالي الاسبق والذي كان تولى رئاسه
الوزراء في ايطاليا لثلاث مرات في تاريخها
اذا وفاه رئيس الوزراء الايطالي سيلفيو
نذهب الان الى كابول ومعنا من هناك عبد
الجبار بهير رئيس المركز الافغاني للاعلام
والدراسات لنتحدث حول هذا التوتر بين
كابول وبين ايضا طهران نتابع معك السيد
بهير الى توزيع المياه ضل مشكله عالقه
لمده 100 عام بين افغانستان وبين طهران هل
يمكن لوكابل اليوم ان تصاعد هذا التوتر
ببناء الصدود مع الجانب الايراني او ممكن
ربما ان تقطع وتعيق تدفق النهر لايران باي
شكل من الاشكال مثلا
طبعا الحكومه الافغانيه كما اوضحت موقفها
عند الاشتباكات يعني قبل شهر تقريبا كان
هناك
يعني خطوات جاده للحكومه الافغانيه تجاه
موقف ايراني وهو ان لابد ان نعتمد على
الاتفاقيه ولابد ان ينفذ كل القرارات من
اهمها بناء السدود هذه بناء السدود على
هذه المياه نهر هيلما سواء كمال خانه يعني
الامرين السددين الذين جعل او ايران
تقول ان انهما عرقله مجرى المياه وقلت في
وصول المياه الى اراضي ايرانيه سواء
لبلوشتان او السيستاني لكن كان هناك
دراسات اكثر من ذلك الحكومه الافغانيه
بدات تدرس الاتفاقيه بكل وضوح في الاعلام
المحلي كان من اهمها ان المياه منعت من
افغانستان مره اخرى ولعل ايران ادركت ان
ان افغانستان جاده
وبدات تجلس على طاوله دراسه هذه الاتفاقيه
لكن لا زالت الموقف الايراني غير واضح هل
هو لبى الطلب الافغاني يجلس على طاوله
المفاوضات او تجلس على على الاتفاقيه
للدراستها ما هو الحق افغانستان الحكومه
الافغانيه تعترف بحق ايران لعل يعني هناك
تبادل الاراء وتبادل كذلك الوفود بين سواء
على الصعيد يعني المياه على الصعيد الامني
كان هناك تردد للوقت الافغاني الى ايران
ومن ايران الى افغانستان ادى الى ان يكون
هناك نوعا ما خف في
في توتر العلاقات والاشتباكات نعم يكون
هناك اشتباك لا يكون اشتباك لكن توتر بين
الحرس الحدودي
لكن لا يقضي على الحدود ماذا لو تصاعد هذا
الامر هل افغانستان هل كابول تحت رئاسه
وقياده طالبان جاهزه لكي تواجه وتجابه
الجانب الايراني فيما يتعلق بازمه المياه
بين الطرفين
بطبيعه الحال يعني الحكومه الافغانيه تؤكد
على انها لا تريد اي توترا مع الجيران
وحالتها السياسيه وموقعها
السياسي الحالي لا زال لان الحكومه غير
معترفه دوليا لا زال هناك ايادي خارجيه
ولعل ايران يعني كل هذه الضغوط هناك
قراءات ان ان تتهم او او تشوه صوره
المستقبليه للحكومه الحاليه لافغانستان
انها لا تؤهل لان تكون حكومه جاده في
افغانستان او المستقبل افغانستان وبالتالي
سيكون هناك ضغوط يعني يعني كل هذه محاولات
ايرانيه لانها تحصل على الماء وانما تدرك
ان ان حقها في الماء واضح في على حسب
الاتفاقيه بين بين ايران وافغانستان وقبل
خمسين سنه تقريبا او قفزه 52 سنه من الان
لكن ضغوط هذه كان هناك في يعني
اشارات الى ان او قراءات الى ان ايران
تريد ان تضغط على افغانستان لان تقبل
متطلبات ايرانيه سواء في الجانب السياسي
او الجانب الاقتصادي واكثر من ذلك في
الخطه السياسيه التي تريدها ايران في
المنطقه من من الحكومه الافغانيه تجاه
يعني اعدائها وتجح حلفائها كذلك في
المنطقه شكرا جزيلا لك من كابول عبد
الجبار بهير رئيس المركز الافغاني للاعلام
والدراسات شكرا لك
في الاثناء قال تقارير عسكريه صينيه ان
طائرات استطلاع تابعه للجيش راقبت مناورات
بحريه امريكيه شاركت فيها فرنسا كندا
واليابان وذكرت تقارير ان الصين استخدم
طائرات شحن مزوده بمعدات مراقبه لمتابعه
المناورات الامريكيه قرب الفلبين في
المحيط الهادئ وجمعت معلومات استخباراتيه
عنها اضافت انها رصدت انشطه قامت بها
حامله طائرات امريكيتان خلال المناورات
الجانبيه قالت خارجيه الصينيه انه لا توجد
حتى الان اي معلومات رسميه حول زياره وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
واضافت في سياق متصل ان التقارير التي
تفيد بتجسس الصين على الولايات المتحده من
كوبا لا اساس لها من الصحه وهي خاطئه هذا
وكان قد اعلن مسؤولون امريكيون ان وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه سيتوجه الى الصين في
نهايه الاسبوع المقبل في زياره كانت قد
ارجعت في فبراير الماضي اثر توغل منطاد
صني في المجال الجوي للولايات المتحده
ونستكمل معكم في هذه الاخبار حيث اجلت
السلطات الفلبينيه اثني عشر الف شخص من
سكان المناطق المجاوره لبركان مايون في
مقاطعه البايل واقعه شمال شرقي البلاد
وذلك بعد ان شوهد البركان وهو ينفذ تيارات
شديده الحراره من الغاز والحطام والصخور
ما يشير الى نشاط تحت السطح ربما يسبق
ثورانا خطيرا
[موسيقى]
في نهايه الصاله الاخباريه لم يبقى الا ان
نذكر بالعناوين
مع تصاعد المعارك في السودان ايجاد تعقد
قمه في جيبوتي لدعوه للحوار ووقف
بعد تحقيق اول مكاسبه في الجيش الاوكراني
يوسع هجومه المضاد ويساعد في ضخمه
في رساله مواجهه لروسيا نيتو يبدا اكبر
مناوره جويه في تاريخه بتنسيق من المانيا
تجدد التوتر على الحدود الافغانيه
الايرانيه وسط خلافات بين البلدين على حصه
مياه نهرها المجد
ولمتابعه ملفات العربيه والمزيد من
الاخبار والتحليلات على موقعنا زوروا
موقعنا العربيات وايضا جميع مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الى هنا تنتهي هذه الساعه
الاخباريه تحيه لكم دوما والى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات